so everybody's asking Pat why are you
calling 2024 the year of chaos let me
explain to you why because 2024 is known
as the greatest election of all time not
because of America but because 40
countries election are happening this
year most ever amount of people voting
in a single year you know what the
number is 3.2 billion that's 41% of the
world $ 44.2 trillion of GDP that's 42%
of the world so what does this do here's
what happens think about the chaotic
place you've ever been What Causes Chaos
the MV chaotic hundreds of people there
right concert chaotic leaving a football
game traffic all parking lot chaotic New
York City chaotic Las Vegas strip New
Year's Eve chaotic airport chaotic What
Causes Chaos a lot of people trying to
get through something fast at the same
time this year 41% of the world is
trying to elect their their leader you
know what countries us we're one of them
India you want me to go through some of
them for you Pakistan Indonesia
Venezuela Mexico Sudan Taiwan Tunisia
Austria Belgium UK South Africa South
Korea European parliamentary election
and more 25 more is happening this year
and the people of power don't like it
when there's so many moving Parts
because they're losing control the
people of power don't like the fact that
there's a lot of losing of power
economically politically you know all
these including spiritually some of
these religion and churches that are
running around the world so today we're
going to make some predictions some of
them are going to come true some of them
are not going to come true but a few of
them are going to get you saying really
you believe that's going to happen yes
we believe this is going to
happen so if you get value out of this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel look when you have a year
like 2024 where everything is predicated
based on Election you have to be
thinking about like the largest
Christian Nation in the world's
elections going on this year us the
largest two countries of Muslims in the
world World elections going on this year
Indonesia and Pakistan simultaneously at
the same time what's the first Tipping
Point because you know when you look at
media we already know one prediction
with elections that's going on in May of
2021 39% of Americans watch cable then
it dropped July 2022 to 34.4% then
January of 2023 went to 30% then July
29% so mainstream media is going lower
and lower and lower first prediction
this will be the last election that
mainstream media is going to have the
majority influence over this is it
mainstream media enjoy it it's going to
be the last one for you cuz 2028
election in American worldwide it ain't
no longer going to be mainstream media
it's going to be complete different
story with podcast independent all those
guys that are doing what they're doing
you will be gone mainstream that's
number one prediction enjoy this final
ride of yours then guess what go retire
your jersey and your teleprompter and
then afterwards maybe even your earpiece
you got to hang it up cuz you got to
figure out how to do this without a
teleprompter there in 20 28 and somebody
telling you what to do cuz that's
changing now let's talk about elections
you know what the pandemic did to us it
made many people lonely in America where
they did not have somebody to talk to
numbers came up saying 33% Americans
feel lonely JP Morgan Chase just came
out talking about 99% Americans are
doing worse today financially than they
were 3 years ago this may be tough times
for some people one of the worst things
you can do is not talk to anybody that's
why today's sponsor is better help what
better help offers you is the
opportunity to connect with over 30,000
license therapists who are trained to
listen and give you helpful and unbiased
advice one of the great things about
better help is sometimes if you want to
go to an office or go meet with a
therapist and talk to somebody cuz you
got nobody in your life you go to an
office you're sitting there other people
are looking at you what if you run to
cooworker family it's a little bit
embarrassing better help you simply do
it on your phone you talk to somebody
but if the therapist doesn't work out
for you they'll replace it with somebody
else at no cost and all you have to do
to get started is fill out a
questionnaire to help assess your
specific needs and you'll get match with
your therapist in most cases within 48
hours or less over 4 million people have
used better betterhelp to live healthier
and happier lives and all you need to do
is click on the link below or go to
betterhelp.com
valut tment to get a 10% discount on
your first month of therapy with a
licensed professional specific to your
needs think about what's going on why I
call this a year of chaos year of chaos
when people panic right oh my God I'm
losing control why are they losing
control you know why tell me movies
where two groups that were pinned
against each other finally realize
they're not each other's enemy behind
closed door somebody is pinning you
against the other person in a movie
Gladiator remember that scene where show
your face Gladiator and he turns around
shows his face and then who unites you
have the emperor you have the fans
Coliseum and you have the Gladiator
right at first they're together all of a
sudden they team up and pin against him
they realize he's the manipulator and
he's the enemy and these guys unite
right you remember that movie in same
with Divergence same with Hunger Games
where you realize somebody is pinning
you against each other you know what's
going on to the world today we're
realizing the people of power who are
afraid of losing their power these
organizations like the world economic
Forum or the World Health Organization
or all these other political elitists
they're afraid cuz you and I are
realizing we're not enemies we're s
looking at you saying why am I hating
you dude I don't I just disagree with
you on six issues I agree with you on 92
other issues what the hell is going on
this year is going to be unification
with weird not everybody of course not
because you can't get everybody but
we're going to unite this year it's
going to be weird they're not going to
like it the manipulators are going to
hate it and we're gradually going to
come here so there's going to be an
element of unification and the people
who you hated 6 years ago people you
voted for seven years ago people you
voted we going to be like he that guy is
not bad as I thought he was going to be
so this is why I think vo says 55%
chance you know who's going to be the
president this year in 2024 it's going
to be Trump that's what they're saying
and by the way I can agree with them I
think Trump's going to win election this
year if nothing crazy happens and so
that's the next prediction I'll make to
you on who's going to be the president I
think think Trump wins election and if
you believe Trump's going to be winning
election you know what that means you
think S&P is going to hit 6,000 before
the end of the year if you're part of
the camp that thinks Trump's going to
get elected s SMP is going to go to
6,000 end of the year if not q1 of next
year could even happen all this year the
other part that we have to be thinking
about one of the most important dates
for the year is going to be August 19th
through August 22nd why that's the DNC
convention Republicans are going to have
it July Democrats are going to have it
in August when that happens in August
here's what many people are going to
think is going to happen between now and
August they got about 7 months 8 months
they have to be thinking about who's
going to be their face in the starting
lineup they know they're not going to
win with Biden because data shows any
presidents approval rating under 40%
doesn't get reelected has never happened
before so if Democrats go into DNC with
that guy being their face what they're
saying is we know we're going to lose
okay so they have seven eight months
behind closed doors guys like Obama's
got to get involved and they got to
start doing some negotiation to replace
Biden and who that person they're going
to replace with there's a lot of people
that see this as an opportunity some
want Michelle Obama's I don't know want
Michelle Hillary's dying to be that
person Democrats don't want Hillary new
wants to be there how is Kamala going to
step down is Biden going to come out and
apologize health is it going to get ugly
nobody knows but that convention that
we're going to hear in August is going
to dictate it's going to be the Tipping
Point of a lot of different things can
you have a formidable person to go up
against Trump we don't know we'll find
out by then so three things so far we've
talked about number one last election
that mainstream media is going to have
majority of the influence in it's done
with number two Trump president November
5th us election it's going to be crazy
but it's not even going to be close and
then next one that we have august 19
through 22nd the DNC convention they
have to introduce to us who their
candidates going to be those events
those second and third event is going to
dictate whether S&P is going to go to
6,000 or S&P is going to go to 3,000
depending on who wins November 5th so
this next part is going to contradict
what I told you on who's going to be the
president because the next part is about
a potential Black Swan event what could
definitely happen this year that's a
little weird all the movies the timing
and everything you know we had pandemic
in 2020 you did not expect that to
happen there could very easily be a
Cyber attack a power grit type of a
crisis taking place in October of this
year imagine if that happens
accidentally oh sorry you know October
18th maybe it's on my birthday a it's a
power grid shut down power is down and
it's China's fault and it's Russia's
fault oops elections came out president
such and such got 92 million votes most
ever how did you count it well we were
counting all of it by hand but guess
what power is back up November 13th and
everything's awesome isn't that great
something crazy like that could also
happen this year now if you we the
people expose all of this gamesmanship
upfront so they know if it does happen
that the people are naive about it then
that can be prevented again if people
unify that can be prevented because
because all they're using is fear of one
side to create the other side as the
enemy as delusional people and they pin
you against each other they sell a
massive crisis called The Grid and
that's why you couldn't vote and one
side's going to say what do you expect
them to do it's all China's fault it's
all Russia's fault no no no it's
internal remember how he started this
video the people who have control and
power don't want to give it up that's
why I call this year the Year of chaos
some of these guys are about to lose a
lot of power they don't like that
they're not accustomed to that they
can't stand that they know 2024 is that
where they're going to have to give up
that power control card so they may be
willing to go and try everything
possible to not give up that power do
not be surprised if that happens here's
the other part that's kind of weird you
know a lot of these companies with all
this crisis that's going on economically
the companies haven't been squeezy to
lay off a lot of people right
unemployment is still relatively around
3 and a half to 4% nothing crazy has
happened however these corporate debt
payments that they're paying they're not
lowering interest rates and yes they're
going to lower the rates this year but
if you look at this chart right here
look at the increase from 2023 to 2024
in Us corporate debt maturity wall and
in 2526 this is not going away so what
are people going to do with that and
what happens if earnings for companies
drops off and all of a sudden you're
hearing these constant earning calls
well they didn't hit their numbers well
they didn't hit their numbers well the
rates are going down yeah but they
didn't hit their numbers what are the
company going to do they just laid off 3
more thousand people they just laid off
2,000 more people they just ra off 4,000
more people well I thought it was going
to Market's going to go up and then
roughly 40% of companies are looking to
replace human employees with AI
technology Google alone is preparing to
lay off 30,000 employees in its ad sales
unit for AI technology transition and
you ready for this next data ready I
mean it may concern you a little bit for
2024 22% of companies planning layoffs
may let go you know what percentage 30%
or more of their employees let me say it
again 22% of companies that's one in
five are planning on laying off more
than 30 percent that's one in three of
their employees in 2024 AI is here if
somebody gets elected that brings the
level of confidence that the consumer
and the voter has they're going to be
delusional they're going at least
somebody's there that's going to be
leading the case right as long as that
person is going to be there I'm going to
be okay so if somewhere in August
September this happened last time in
2016 in 2016 an article came out saying
Wall Street and New York has said that
Hillary Clinton's going to be the
president 80% chance that day the market
dropped nearly points cuz everybody was
afraid but flip it St article comes out
and says there's an 82% chance that
Trump is going to get elected president
on November 5th there could be a day of
the market going like this 1100 points
1,200 points if some very influential
name say something like that so again
but this corporate debt payment and what
these number this is not like a thing
that has to do with the economy this has
to do with something that we've been
waiting for the season to come it could
come out any time in 2024 again we'll
see one thing to look out for in 2024
when it comes down to war in 2022 we had
more casualties due to war than we had
in the late 80s okay we haven't had it
for a long time since the ' 80s and in
2023 beats 2022 so 2024 what's going to
happen well if we look at data this is
what I would tell us what is common
between 2021 2022 and 2023 it's called a
very weak leader and president in
America his name is Joseph Biden nice
guy but he sleeps took 37% of his
presidency he taking vacation what does
that do an i opportunity for enemies to
attack so if that Trend continues in
2024 and there's some other people that
are sitting there saying hey man
taiwan's got an election coming up and
we're China is this our opportunity to
do something maybe will they will they
not I'm convinced there's a part of
these people that are capitalizing that
also want America to have a stronger
leader to lower the temperature these
same big people that go like this I
think they want America to become
stronger to lower the temperature Around
The Reckless bullies worldwide that we
seeing in the Middle East and some other
places North Korea the other day said If
America does something we have what it
takes to attack America today what he
said this just last week what are you
talking about little weird little crazy
unfortunately we got one more year to go
with a president in America that nobody
fears and nobody respects in terms of
war that part is a little way too
unpredictable to see what's going to
happen somebody could say this is our
last chance to do something with an
enemy that we have way before a person
like Trump gets reelected in America two
last things to be thinking about number
one remember when Banks were going out
of business and America came up with
this Bank term funding program to
prevent Banks from going out of business
that's set to expire this March 2024
with a crazy year like this knowing with
commercial real estate which is my
second point it's estimated
$650 billion in property debt maturing
in 2024 those guys going to want to get
their payments at the high interest rate
a lot of these guys owning this
commercial real estate property they're
not going to be able to make those
payments Bang who gave up this money now
rates are going so high it's going to be
nasty which means again that program is
going to continue way past the month of
March and I think this year in certain
Pockets we're already experiencing
commercial real estate in certain areas
uh property in LA Downtown LA the Aon
building 10 years ago was sold for $268
million just closed this week this last
week for $153 million think about you
bought a building for $268 million and
you sell it for $150 million commercial
real estate is going to get destroyed in
certain markets this year cuz rates are
coming up and they don't have a choice
but to make those payments if you got
value out of this video give it a thumbs
up subscribe to the channel and if you
don't know what a zombie company is I
highly recommend you study what the hell
is going on with all these zombie
companies in America that rely to pay
their salaries to survive purely on
borrowing money the numbers are
staggering if you've not seen it click
here to watch it take care everybody
bye- bye
bye-bye